hello and welcome to this video played I
am Barry o from an Argentine you'll be
place some Kings Indian attack style
looks like it later 3 n 2 D 3 Pablo
borrow your navel bury your nuevo ok I
like to take the space there immediately
ok take directly attacking this so let's
cover can be five and it's a look it
looks a bit like a samish things ended
with reverse colors the only em and
current thing is that early night
maneuvers ok got that trigger ok then
let's let's keep this Bishop it still
have more space here typical of the
Kings Indian and I think blackest is
better here i also have not cancelled
yet it's quite important and i will get
in b5 those nights are not very well
positioned and question is B 5 or we
could be eight first I think would be
eight first mp3 ok and this is this is
not a good move it just weakens the
queenside long-term and yeah it doesn't
have anything on the Kings side at all I
have not cashed out so
ok so a couple of good things that I can
try even King this seven as a good move
let's do that get the position yeah the
rooks connected move the Queen next oh
wow I guess me the default square I can
go 94 even here right right before this
before no I can also do this I mean it
just just a pretty pretty nice position
and okay if I put the night in there
immediately then there's some group a
seven so let's prevent that
I play 94 next is still sitting on that
stupid-looking bishop on age three
okay so just take it I guess keep it
simple play with the night night against
bishop and again a surprising move
allowing me to and played III now I get
denied to deform
I thought he had to take with the people
looked like the only move white resigns
yeah I get night to defiant he cannot
defend b3 and is playing a piece down
here on age three basically yeah
somewhat strange game um yeah okay he
got this tactic and this is a nice
little device so if i take then this way
he has weakened the the light squares on
my own but I can so retreat um I think
he has to try to somehow disturb my
position a little bit here maybe Queen
g4 or something concrete the way it went
and f 497 and I think after f5 I'm
strategically more or less winning or
clearly better because he doesn't get a
quick g45 in there's no nothing concrete
threatening and I get the screen side
play and note that this kind of thing is
only stalling blacks play it can never
prevent it entirely and we saw how
quickly this happens yeah I could have
gone before immediately but yeah and b3
is the next questionable move you should
try to not move pawn stay on this side
we already we quickly see what happened
yeah I could I went in for this invasion
and now it's difficult to tolerate this
Bishop he tried for a while but couldn't
really am yes standards dentist tension
is is already very bad
night comes them and here he has to take
with the beep on I mean in fact I can do
almost the same thing the same idea and
get here a bit this is this is this is
absolutely disastrous now with the night
coming down it's it's an early
resignation but there's simply nothing
that that white can try here I know
something like this how are you stopping
all this rugae three maybe and so on
okay thanks for watching